for the big fella Hardin played by ball  backing his way goes to the fadeaway  James Hardie 35 points 10 assists 5  rebounds is just a beautiful turn around  he's gonna turn around and give you the  step back on that left hip let's see if  party stays in the pick-and-roll by the  Lakers seem like they've been selling  for jumpers hardly fire sake on that  play both guys were determined to get a  play for their team Harvey  [Applause]  [Music]  just to the shock gets credit his  hardened James  36 points he's gonna read out away from  a triple double of a stretch plane seven  of nine at home I just believe it shuts  out all my gosh you focus at this  organization about everything it has to  offer  and so will complete your bills I gotta  continue to get better a bug visit of  welcome to the ball and uh great